hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play Orcs Must Die - okay
we're just rolling right along here we
go into the next level where we got
dwarf Guardians
ah crap I didn't spend my skulls I
didn't either Oh barricades oh wait no
we get dwarf anyway you can use him I'm
[Music]
actually maybe I'll try it I'm gonna try
it yeah and I put them on the barricades
whoa look at that
what see that what is it
hit giant bundle a bomb alright now I
like it I'm sure responds maybe hmm well
I mean no doubt this is actually really
cool there's all these barricades set up
but I think they kind of do our
problematic because they're gonna split
them up yeah but you can put the doors
behind him oh the last level the last
layer of barricades are like completely
full like they don't allow anyone
through oh really yeah okay either way
I'm just gonna have to war on Bob's up
there can I put him up there
no I cannot alright whatever hmm look
protect my dwarf war brethren through
God
okay ready stab it
ah crap they're going to go in all sorts
of directions are they yeah I figured
they would bomb actually those are just
going to the right well what good are my
dwarves doing if they're in the middle
my drawers are pretty packed shut up I
don't care about your doors my dwarves
are the best okay maybe those bums don't
reset
I'm actually starting to think that they
do
mm-hmm
whoosh whoosh
hey how you got in my way do i do live
me
one's got behind us oh we're I'm just
kidding
totally nice idea I'm selling these
works cuz they don't do anything
I guess I'll put them on the right baby
oh crap what not these
what don't blow up the bed all the blue
all
no need to panic we got this covered out
or if the same rule applies and you
still get healed near the rift ID now
they're going through the center
okay the barricades on the right are
like completely destroyed now how great
my cousin no actually I wonder if the
dwarves will puppies look blow up the
barricades and can they do that
I I don't know I'm starting to think
that though
oh they got my what are you doing I got
him
what are you doing I must I'm up with
sticky traps and my captain here Oh
why do they head straight for the
barricades that's stupid
well that's what their goal is to
destroy the barricade is that their goal
I hardly use barricades in them
what's my study what Rayleigh yeah I
hardly ever I use barricades all the
time well aren't you just a giant noob
they're good for funneling they're good
for your face - yep
oh no the wharf is down those Dwarfs
suck at Oh Risa I know but they still
suck yeah they suck pretty bad the
guardians are way better oh crap they're
getting through em I said too but I
boost them back yes - Boosh your dwarves
are down man it's fine another backup
but yeah we're kind of not doing so good
here maybe we should like you know slow
them down a bit yeah okay whatever you
say boss
we're back here is not doing anything
socks
I must sell them screw him up selling
him don't don't head you yet screw it
I'm selling
man just sticky trap pendulum was the
[ __ ] oh yeah I mean that's basically all
you needed with the with the wind where
you could push him back all you needed
complete anything with sticky trap
pendulum
okay already I think we're ready all
right nope not today little guys I said
not today man I swear they dropped the
hitboxes on everything he's fine to me
shut up you got the word etter you got
the better I'm using an AoE weapon
those are starting weapon jeez I know
not fear I can also do this now I can do
this
we're going through the center that's
awfully nice of them
coming team don't get in my way but I
was oh that's what happens if we shoot
those cards what they spill love on them
ah how am i helpful a while ago she like
just yeah sweet other sauce of this
oh nice
that's a lot of them kind of a lot we
got this GUI mister coming down the
center let's get those big guys down I
can't blow them back [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay okay good we got our big layer of
scuffing knock these things over
and there we go
the primary easy-peasy lemon squeezy
spike traps backups backup this'll hurt
oops wrong yep
okay sappers going up a set why haven't
you sold this dwarf yet did that my door
as your dwarf oh I forgot about it I
placed a mirror at the very beginning
well I'll stupid was that of you oh crap
what are you doing what are you doing
I'm over here in my spot
got that want me to Bush them
fine no I'm fine if you're no problem
okay
a dwarf is down and there's so many
carts she's been using then a long time
ago
ah crap
I think it's fine doesn't sound fine you
look like you're out of mana and low on
health no I'm not going on there there
I'm fine oh oh I got her Salaam
elementals coming up my ass
so do I I'm out of money no traps big
guys Oh No done what Oh oh my goodness I
got a little help would be lovely little
help would be lovely little help would
be lovely
I'm helping as much as I can nope too
late it's gone thank you thank you thank
you I help those who help themselves
thank you for nothing wait wait I gotta
sell that Dorf oh crap he's dead I can't
sell
oh fast guys are coming up we're non
explode ease right so got him I kind of
wish I had the blunderbuss again at
least it had a grenade
I have no way we stuff write them up to
the thought of that
shut up so saying I should have thought
of that
died
and these I square okay that was easy
earth elementals if you had shot a
better
I just got a not spam ever spamming is
more punished in this version than the
old one definitely I gotta die yeah my
weapon all I can do is spam on its
regular attack I wish I could do that
huh here's your dick
okay now you can sell your dwarf yeah
good man that guy is useless get out of
here
I'm just locking up the center area so
we can get some spamming or the initial
area all right last one
we're not lovers oh crap I lived for
mass or Billy
I'm steadily getting better at this
headshot thing not good but better I say
just before I miss ten bazillion
headshots still missing still missing
still missing amazingly still missing
huh how you doing over there that looks
like a lot of red dots on my mini-map
and I can't even hit the carts what is
wrong with me
Hill's drink what is wrong with me stops
what's wrong with me I don't know
coming up the right and left now it
split
it sound like a bowling pins on the
goldens fall down yeah
are you doing over there fine fine I'm
doing good how are you nice here this is
Gollum SEP John Gant ahead that's all I
can say about that don't know why they
don't drop coins okay last one
[Applause]
you
okay you got that so I'll go over to my
side Oh looks like my spike traps are
working better put some more
I've run out of Emmys oh good for you go
find some more
I see you scoff I'm gonna get it I'll go
get my Oh
epic combo with the sappers ah ones
coming up the middle crap I've got lots
over here I got it I got the middle one
got it coming up the middle again don't
forget you're sad to blow them back
whoosh huh bish a beer shoot
I'm gonna bond you find me no I am there
not I
yeah what well four to five again what
did you do what did you do Rihanna what
oh yeah we let tons through what are we
talking about all right we got the
barricade now oh we got the barricade
what a bunch of crap it's my favorite
one that's not mine
all right anyway that's all the time we
got for this episode thank you guys so
much for watching and as always we'll
see you in the next part bye bye bye